what had elon musk was going to
reinstate donald trump to twitter i
gotta admit i smiled i've kind of missed
it it's been a bit boring without him
and his own particular brand of raging
perma controversy and there were
wonderful moments like this
none of us will ever forget where we
were when we read this and thought what
the hell's he talking about we still
have no idea what he was talking about
nobody was safe from trump's tweets he
had a go at london mayor sadiq khan
calling him a terrible mayor and
foolishly nasty this was after sadiq
khan allowed a big gigantic grotesque
balloon to fly over parliament square
during trump's state visit
today sadiq khan said this about the
idea of trump was coming back to twitter
the art of racial abuse i received
on social media
increased by two thousand percent
two thousand percent in trump's first
year in the last year being being
president
once he was banned from twitter
i received the least racial abuse of any
time
over five years
well should he be allowed back joining
me now is conservative radio host ben
ferguson i'm pretty good at the vista
campaign gina miller welcome to both of
you um ben i'll come to you in a moment
gina lovely to see you thank you for
coming to the the thing jack dorsey uh
has defended uh elon musk saying trump
should come back he said he does agree
but he had so got some exceptions he
said in terms of behavior spam network
manipulation illegal behavior but
generally he said permanent bans are a
failure of ours don't work and he said
it was a business decision and they
shouldn't make business decisions about
freedom of speech
i have to i agree with him because um
you know one of the things that elon
musk said was that um he is a free
speech absolutist well that means he's
black and white and actually life is
shades of gray so there's some it's
quite worrying that he said that and
he's going to be if the deal goes
through in charge of twitter but i think
it's um free speech is different from
inciting violence or fueling hatred or
you know the integrity of an electoral
system but saying someone you know
abusing someone and disagreeing with
them or being harsh on them you have
every right to say that right
so
getting racist abuse because donald
trump uh criticized him on twitter i
didn't see i don't see how you can make
that connection well i thought it was a
bit serious because i didn't see donald
trump encouraging people to be racist
about sadiq khan he was criticizing him
he got 80 million followers including a
lot of idiots clearly who thought it was
okay to racially abuse him ben ferguson
the argument against bringing donald
trump back is that he incited violence
on january the 6th of the capital and
that was why he got banned that was the
reason twitter had at the time i've got
to say that when you when you think that
vladimir putin the supreme iran leader
and the taliban chiefs are all still on
twitter it seems a ridiculous moment
that the president of united states
is not there
yeah it was it was their excuse they
were looking for an excuse to silence
what many would argue is the most
powerful man on twitter at the time
donald trump and that was their excuse
they were waiting for an opportunity and
you notice within a couple of hours
everything had banned him right from
social media facebook jumped on there
sites that allow you to sell goods even
banned him because they hated donald
trump and if you look at twitter and you
look at their big problem now it's even
when they say that he should come back
under certain guidelines those own
guidelines still don't apply to vladimir
putin to isis leaders to al qaeda the
ayatollah i mean the list goes on and on
and on of people you even had someone
last week that threatened supreme court
justices by giving out their addresses
and say you will not feel safe until you
are dead in the ground and they didn't
even suspend that twitter account so the
idea that twitter is out there going oh
we're gonna we're gonna have law and
order here is absurd and they should
allow people to come back and if you
don't like what they say then fine you
as a user have the option to never look
at donald trump's tweets again i mean
that's the point i would say is you know
with free speech people sometimes get it
wrong i think what free speech is you
know you don't have to listen to you can
block people on twitter i do that a lot
if they're just really horrendously
abusive i think at the moment with this
whole conversation which is actually
lots of shades of grey is that um we're
looking at the medium not the message
because actually there are lots of if
you did that if you spray painted
graffiti which incited violence then
that's illegal just because you're doing
it on social media it should be the same
rules so the rules that should not be
applied to the medium it's the message
would you ban trump
i would
it would would you extend the ban
otherwise not bring it well i i think it
wasn't a life ban but i think i would
look at it and see that he there
were times when he incited hatred and he
did fuel insurgents and he did cause um
violent incite violence and those are
things that are illegal in states in the
america not all not free
for you know freedom of speech is
interesting because in in the us under
the first amendment of constitution
there is actually no legislation for
hate speech as we do in most western
countries so territories different
countries
differ very much and twitter is a global
platform which creates its own problems
it has huge problems there but not only
that you've got this you have to apply
whatever the rule is consistently across
everyone and also you have to not just
make this about celebrities or
politicizing everything because actually
there are real problems with pornography
with self-harm with lots of other things
right on this platform so ben focus i
mean my issue with this is not a free
speech issue well well ben i want to
come to let me know let me put this to
you ben i mean i i had a case on
instagram where some vile job in this
country in the uk posted a death threat
specific to me and one of my sons on his
instagram page in public it's going
through the legal process now it's taken
16 months i have to say and there's
still be no charging decision but i was
absolutely incensed that someone would
target one of my kids like that with a
with a genuinely
horrible death threat and i've decided
to pursue it that to me there is a line
and i think we do know where a lot of
these lines are
yeah and i agree with you and i think
that's common sense but this idea
that that twitter should have rules like
someone's a kindergartner first grade
teacher and we're gonna put you in time
out in the corner because you say
something that we just don't like or you
have an opinion that we just don't like
is never going to work and i think
that's what dorsey even understood now
yes you can have rules that you can't
threaten to kill somebody for example as
you just described i've dealt with death
threats before as well and when you deal
with it when it comes after your family
it is very personal and the fact that it
takes so long to get them taken down
when you report them but they will go
after people for political speech is
where there is a clear as he put it
black and white there is not a gray area
here you either have a platform that's
in favor of free speech and you can have
rules like no death threats right but
this idea that donald trump is banned
but but vladimir putin and isis and al
qaeda leaders still have that it's crazy
it's christian it tells you that this
was about targeting him politically it
was not about yeah i think i securing up
yeah that's it's definitely been a bias
against conservative right in terms of
who gets the platform and it even went
to the extent where the new york post
had
their own account on twitter you know
d-platform because they had a genuinely
true story about a laptop belonging to
the president's side it was ridiculous
i think there is
too much of this be is being made
political football that's absolutely
true because there are real crimes
happening on social media platforms as
you said by the way in your case maybe
you should quote my precedence because
actually the same thing happened with me
and i did get someone sent to jail for
exactly that threatening to kill me and
children etc so you know those sorts of
things those are black and white i
absolutely agree with that but
expressing dislike or prejudice isn't
that is free speech inciting violence
and actually fueling hate and dis and
destabilizing democracy now those to me
are also black and white and that's what
i think trump should have been banned
for not for having views that we don't
you wouldn't necessarily give him a lie
you do believe that trump should be paid
not not for a lifetime i think you know
what we should do maybe a two strike
rules so how can you put them in time
all right final point
this is this is where you lose me you
just said that you would ban trump so my
question is for how long and would you
abandon right before an election and use
that to your advantage would you wait
for it right before a midterm election
or or a prime minister or any type of
election in the world and then you let
people politically you know because
that's why
that they want to shut up that's the
problem if you do it the way you're
describing it it will be used to
undermine freedom and democracy okay and
election results
undermine people
the argument with trump is did did he
actually break the law by inciting the
rights of the capital no he didn't well
but there is an argument about that some
people think he did some people think he
didn't it's still going through courts
we'll find out eventually what the
conclusion is on all that but it's a
very interesting debate i don't think
there are easy answers i'm actually glad
elon musk is the one to tackle them
because he has a massive brain and i
think these need a massive brain a bit
like you ben ferguson
brains